storytime this reminds me of when I
first started building things with wood
so I went down to Home Depot I bought
some wood I bought a hammer and a box of
nails and suddenly I could build things
I went crazy with it I built all kinds
of small things occasionally hitting my
finger but generally I was successful
eventually though hammers and nails
didn't quite cut it so I saved up some
money and I upgraded I bought a screw
gun and some screws about a chop saw I
even bought some of these and I built
all kinds of cool things with these
tools and the things I built were much
better because my tools were better then
I wanted to build an actual structure
like something I could stand on and
guess what I didn't trust my own designs
I knew that if I took my methods from
all those small projects and scaled them
up I built something that wouldn't hold
my weight which would be bad now I
didn't need to go out and buy new tools
I had everything I needed everything
physical at least what I did need was
some organizational guidance and some
new building techniques so I spent some
time experimenting I discovered that if
I separated out my sections of my
project into different pieces that
attach to each other it'd be easier to
build potentially more stable and much
easier to change later then eventually I
googled around and I got even better
techniques that way things of would have
taken me a long time to figure out on my
own now this is exactly where you are
right now you have great tools you know
JavaScript
you know the features of the language
but you do need to learn better
organizational techniques so your
applications are stable and bug-free
cleanly written they scale well and are
extensible